diese innovative idee könnte tatsächlich
irgendwann mal das ende von hungersnöten
weltweit bedeuten ein forschungsteam aus
finnland hat es geschafft mit speziell
entwickelten bioreaktor nachhaltige
protein mahlzeiten herzustellen und zwar
aus kohlendioxid ein paar nährstoff
mikroorganismen und ein bisschen
sonnenlicht und das emissionsfrei kriegs
und science fiction hier gibt es täglich
videos rund um science abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er kein video
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
das ist wirklich eine geschichte
nahrungsmittel aus licht und
kohlendioxid die benötigten bioreaktoren
sind zudem anders als die landwirtschaft
unabhängig von externen umwelteinflüssen
wie dem wetter und kaum zu glauben aber
die entwickelten bioreaktoren sind
gerade einmal so groß wie eine tasse
kaffee dort drin hat das forschungsteam
aus finnland tatsächlich aus einer
wässrigen lösung eine kleine menge an
festen material geworden konkret wurden
dafür mikroorganismen freies
kohlendioxid und wasser benötigt durch
solarenergie kam es zur elektrolyse er
kennt das leicht aus dem
chemieunterricht bei diesem prozess
bewirkt elektrizität eine aufspaltung
komplexer substanzen zwei wochen dauerte
es bis die bioreaktoren mit der
produktion fertig waren das ergebnis
eine pulvrige biomasse und konkret etwa
ein gramm protein pulver das zur hälfte
aus proteinen also eiweißen besteht
jeweils weitere ein viertel verteilen
sich auf kohlenhydrate sowie auf
nukleinsäuren und fette die so
produzierte biomasse könnte sehr
vielfältig genutzt werden zum einen wie
schon erwähnt als nahrungsmittel dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher
juha pekka pitt kennen in zukunft kann
die technologie beispielsweise in wüsten
und anderen gebieten mit häufig
auftretenden hungersnöten transportiert
werden eine mögliche alternative ist so
etwas wie ein haus reaktor also eine art
haushaltsgerät mit dem die verbraucher
das benötigte protein produzieren können
anders als die landwirtschaft wäre man
hiermit nicht durch umwelteinflüsse wie
etwa das wetter eingeschränkt dazu der
wissenschaftler dollar im vergleich zur
traditionellen landwirtschaft wichtig
diese produktionsmethode keine
bestimmten standort wird kommt so was
wie die richtige temperatur feuchtigkeit
oder ein
die bodenart die methode erfordert zudem
keine schädlingsbekämpfung nur
erneuerbare energien wie beispielsweise
in form von solarenergie müssen
verfügbar seien zudem sind die
bioreaktoren nur klein und nehmen nicht
viel platz weg da die prozesse
ausschließlich in den reaktoren selbst
stattfinden gibt es auch keine negativen
auswirkungen auf die umwelt der
herstellungsprozess ist nach angabe des
forschungsteams tatsächlich komplett
nachhaltig anders als die landwirtschaft
in deutschland grünflächen werden den
ackerland umgewandelt und düngemittel
omas eingesetzt all das ist nach angaben
des bundesumweltamtes zweitgrößte
ursache von treibhausgasen und das
protein könnte auch noch durch die
verarbeitung zu tierfutter als mögliche
problemlösung des weltweiten hunger
problems beitragen im besten fall
könnten so die derzeit für
landwirtschaft genutzten flächen frei
gemacht werden beispielsweise für die
forstwirtschaft doch auch in einem ganz
anderen bereich könnte das so
hergestellte proteine eingesetzt werden
in der raumfahrt nämlich schließlich
entspricht es in seiner zusammensetzung
einem grundnahrungsmittel eine wichtige
voraussetzung bei langen weltraum
aufenthalten doch es gibt noch
herausforderungen die das forschungsteam
noch angehen muss wie bereits erwähnt
braucht es bislang zwei wochen um gerade
einmal ein gramm zu produzieren heißt
also deutlich größere mengen müssen her
dafür muss das konzept des reaktors
optimiert werden genauso wie die
steuerung des prozesses ansicht doch das
forschungsteam aus finnland ist
optimistisch und will zukünftig ein
massenprodukt daraus machen und somit
auch eine kommerzialisierung möglich
machen wo das video haben wir übrigens
zuerst in englisch veröffentlicht wenn
ihr premieren dort auf dem englischen
kanal nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert den kanal einfach einfach hier
draufklicken und darunter geht es weiter
mit name watts become reality robots in
your body bis dann bleibt dran